في الشارع الايرانيه امال عريضه على العام
الجديد مجموعه من الشخصيات المعارضه
المقيمه في المنفى نشرت رساله تتوقع بان
يكون 20 23 بان يكون عام 20 23 عام النصر
على النظام ولا طالما اعتبرت المعارضه في
المنفى اعتبرت مشرذمه ومنقسمه في التعامل
مع النظام الحاكم منذ 79 لكن في ظل
الاستمرار الاحتجاجات يبدو ان الامر يتغير
في مضمون الرساله رساله العام 20 22 كان
رائعا لجهه تضامن الايرانيين من كل معتقد
ولغه وانه مع التنظيم والتضامن سيكون عام
20 23 عام مصر للامه الايرانيه هذا ما
تعتبره المعارضه في الخارج الان الرساله
نشرتها بشكل متزام على وسائل التواصل
شخصيات عده انطلاقا من المعارضه البارزه
مسيح علي نجاد وصولا الى نجم
كما نشرت الممثلتان الشهيرتان اكتشفت
فرحاني ونذانين بن يدي الرساله اضافه الى
زهره امير ابراهيم التي نال جائزه افضل
ممثله في مهرجان كان السينمائي العام
الماضي وكتبت فرهاني على حسابها في
انستغرام نقف صفا واحدا للوصول الى الحريه
سنقف معا ولن نلزم الصمت تضم قائمه
الناشطين مدافعين عن حقوق الانسان الذين
نشروا الرساله شيرين عبادي الحائز جائزه
نوبل للسلام وحامد اسماعيل الذي قاد حمله
مقرها كندا للمطالبه بالعداله لضحايا رحله
الخطوط الجويه الاوكرانيه التي اسقطتها
ايران في يناير 2020 اما في مجال الرياضه
فنشر الرساله نجم كره القدم الدولي السابق
علي كريمه وهو احد ابرز مؤيدي الحركه
الاحتجاجيه
الرساله اخذت صدا واسعا لدى الايرانيين
واعتبرها معارض ايراني انها مؤشر يبعث على
الامل في فتره مظلمه فهل يكون عام 20 23
عاما النصر